[Música]
el Consejo Nacional de Ecuador tendrá
hasta el 24 de mayo para convocar
elecciones legislativas y presidenciales
después de que el presidente Guillermo
lasso aplicará el mecanismo conocido
como muerte Cruzada la disolución de la
asamblea nacional se dio en medio de un
juicio político contra el mandatario
el parlamento chileno aprobó una ley de
regalías que eleva la carga tributaria a
la producción de cobre con la que el
gobierno de Gabriel boric Busca recaudar
el 0,45% del pib chile es el mayor
productor mundial de cobre Tenemos
reporte desde Santiago con las
reacciones
el presidente salvadoreño nayib bukele
justificó en el asesinato de un oficial
una nueva prórroga del estado de
excepción arremetido contra las ong
defensoras de derechos humanos y
prometió arrasar con los que calificó de
asesinos
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano mi
nombre Rodrigo sedano es un placer estar
con ustedes abrimos en Ecuador donde
este miércoles el presidente Guillermo
lasso aplicó la muerte Cruzada un
procedimiento que le permitió disolver
la asamblea nacional y convocar
elecciones el hecho ocurrió Un día
después que el mandatario se presentará
en el congreso para exponer su defensa
en un juicio político en el que la
oposición lo acusaba de presunto
peculado el Consejo Nacional electoral
tendrá hasta el 24 de mayo para llamar a
los comicios generales Alba Santana con
los detalles
tan solo unas horas después de la muerte
Cruzada como se conoce a la disolución
de la Asamblea Nacional en Ecuador y la
convocatoria de nuevas elecciones
he decidido aplicar el artículo
148 de la Constitución de la república
que me otorga la Facultad de disolver la
asamblea nacional el país andino ya está
sumido en un inédito proceso electoral
que durará 90 días y con unos comicios
especiales habrá una sola vuelta
Guillermo lasso podrá volver a ser
candidato y quien resulte electo
gobernará hasta mayo del 2025 la fecha
de las nuevas elecciones se anunciará el
24 de mayo o antes
aunemos esfuerzos para dar mayor
tranquilidad al país y sobre todo de que
este nuevo momento que atraviesa el
Ecuador se fortalezca cada vez más
nuestra democracia
la función electoral está lista mientras
el presidente lazo podrá gobernar hasta
seis meses por decreto un poder que ya
usó Este miércoles con una reforma
tributaria para bajar los impuestos algo
por lo que ha recibido duras críticas de
la oposición tanto del correísmo como de
la conaye los indígenas aseguran saldrán
a las calles si lo consideran necesario
el pueblo es el mandante no un caído y
defenestrado presidente este escenario
no puede ser usado para criminalizar y
violentar los Derechos Humanos los
derechos de los Ecuatorianos algunos
países de la región o como chile han
expresado su preocupación otros como
Perú Estados Unidos o México confían en
que el país vuelva a la normalidad con
las elecciones Ojalá y los hermanos
Ecuatorianos puedan resolver esto así
este
con este procedimiento en medio de esta
crisis política las autoridades
ecuatorianas están pendientes de una
posible movilización social en Chile el
país mayor productor del Cobre del mundo
el parlamento aprobó por amplia mayoría
una ley de regalías que eleva la carga
tributaria a la producción de cobre con
la que el gobierno de Gabriel borich
Busca recaudar el 0,45% del pib dentro
de la medida se contempla una tasa
impositiva máxima del
46,5% de la ganancia operativa para las
empresas que produzcan más de 80.000
toneladas nuestra corresponsal en
Santiago Patricia Luna nos amplía el
congreso chileno aprobó por amplia
mayoría 101 votos a favor 24 en contra y
tres ascensiones el royalti minero que
incrementa la recaudación de impuestos
sobre la producción de cobre de la que
chile es uno de los mayores productores
del mundo el royalty que ha de ser
todavía promulgado por el presidente
Gabriel borics quien se felicitó por
esta iniciativa fija en un 46,5% la
carga impositiva máxima para aquellas
empresas que traspasen un umbral de
producción y un 45,5% para otras de
media se sitúa todavía por detrás de
otros países productores como Perú o
Australia la sociedad nacional minera
señaló el impacto que esto va a tener en
la competitividad del sector pidió
incentivos para la inversión pero
también valoro positivamente que se
acabe la incertidumbre puesto que la
norma tardó más de cuatro años en ser
tramitada en el congreso y también
valoro positivamente que El Ejecutivo
redujera de 50% inicial a
46,5% la carga tributaria máxima esto
permitirá al gobierno de Gabriel borich
recaudar 1350 millones de dólares
anuales 450 de los cuales se van a
dedicar al desarrollo de las regiones
muchas de las cuales se verán por
primera vez favorecidas por la
extracción de cobre en el país
Vamos hasta el Salvador ahí el gobierno
de nayib bukele extendió por décimo
cuarta vez el estado de excepción tras
la muerte de un policía presuntamente a
manos de pandilleros esto pese a las
denuncias de ongs y organismos
internacionales sobre abusos de poder y
presuntas violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos bukele volvió a decir a través
de Twitter que meterán en prisión a
todos los asesinos para que no salgan
jamás anteriormente nuestro corresponsal
en San Salvador Vladimir Chamorro nos
contaba hasta cuándo podría ampliarse y
cuáles son las últimas acciones que se
han llevado a cabo
Hola es sí las autoridades de seguridad
han sido empáticos que el régimen de
excepción se extenderá las veces que sea
necesario Hasta que el último miembro de
las pandillas sea encarcelado este día
pues se ha dado una vuelta de tuerca a
la drástica estrategia de seguridad con
la implementación de un nuevo ser con
militar El quinto de este tipo en el
marco del régimen de excepción que
cumplen catorce meses que implica esto
es una mayor operatividad
de la de las fuerzas de seguridad
mayores bueno mayor número de
allanamientos en viviendas controles
vehiculares etcétera este último cerco
militar fue instalado instalado en el
municipio de Nueva Concepción en el
norte del país luego del asesinato de la
gente policial primera vez que ocurre un
asesinato de este tipo durante el
régimen de excepción decir que podríamos
seguir esperando que te siga prorrogando
este régimen de excepción las veces
durante muchos meses hasta que como ha
dicho el mismo presidente bukele el
último pandillero esté tras las rejas el
medio estadounidense Wall Street journal
reportó este miércoles que el Gobernador
de Florida ron de santis hará pública su
candidatura presidencial la semana que
viene el journal habla de una avalancha
de donaciones a esta campaña y cita a
Fuentes cercanas con la decisión de
Santi se perfila como el principal rival
de Donald Trump en la aspiración por la
nominación del partido republicano y ha
buscado atraer seguidores impulsando
medidas ultra conservadoras en su estado
por ejemplo este miércoles firmó una
nueva ley que prohíbe la atención médica
de afirmación de género y también
promulga obstáculos para que los adultos
accedan al tratamiento
y en la ciudad de Nueva York con una
persecución de paparazzis estuvo cerca
de acabar en tragedia para el príncipe
Harry para su esposa Meghan y para la
madre de ésta así lo denunció el
portavoz de Los Duques de sasex en un
comunicado en el que detalló que la
pareja fue perseguida por más de dos
horas la policía de Nueva York confirmó
sin embargo que no se reportaron choques
heridas o arrestos el alcalde de la
ciudad Se pronunció
está claro que los paparazzis de la
prensa quieren obtener la toma correcta
quieren obtener la historia correcta
pero la seguridad pública siempre debe
estar por delante
[Música]
según el informe que recibí dos de
nuestros oficiales Podrían haber
resultado heridos
la ciudad de Nueva York es diferente a
un pequeño pueblo en algún lugar no
deberías ir a toda velocidad a ningún
lado pero esta es una ciudad densamente
poblada
y terminamos esta informativo con un
nuevo récord guinness alcanzado por el
aventurero británico Jamie McDonald's
quien recorrió las siete maravillas del
mundo en tan solo 7 días comenzó la Gran
Muralla China pasó luego por el Taj
Mahal Petra en Jordania el Coliseo
romano y culminó en el continente
americano visitó el Cristo Redentor de
Río Machu Picchu y Chichén Itzá el
originario de glowster viaja un total de
36.783 kilómetros tomó para ello 13
vuelos 16 taxis 9 buses y cuatro trenes
para lograr esta proeza
con estas imágenes del aventurero en
Machu Picchu Nos despedimos sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]